one of the common misconceptions about  our summer rainfall is that when we get  a big storm we may see flooding on the  news we may see that you know  substantial lightning and maybe some  storm destruction and i often get people  who ask me did that end the drought  and and that's not going to end the  drought the water that's in the colorado  river system and lake mead comes  primarily from the high mountains and  the snowpack in wyoming colorado and  utah and that's going to be the bulk of  all the water that enters the system so  while rainfall may help us reduce our  demand on our supplies don't count on  rainfall to fill up lake mead and end  our drought  so when we get those rains and there are  so very few of them it's really  important that we respond so don't  forget  when it rains do your part and shut down  your irrigation